si je vous ai bien compris vous êtes en
train de dire à la prochaine fois
quatre ans après le ciel du rêve de
faire du québec un état souverain
rené lévesque accepte de donner une
chance ou fédéralisme canadien
si le fédéralisme devait fonctionner
moins mal les mêmes vraiment s'améliorer
est-ce que ça risque pas d'étouffer un
peu notre option fondamentale et de
renvoyer la souveraineté aux calendes
grecques
de toute évidence il ya un élément de
risque mais c'est un bon fils et qu'on
n'a pas le loisir de toute façon de
refuser le beau risque de rené lévesque
provoque une rupture journée 12
ministres de son gouvernement dix
missions du taux de dons louise harel
qui ministre de l'immigration depuis
seulement deux mois
je m'oppose à mise au rancart de notre
option je n'aurais jamais sonné troquer
mes convictions pour un poste de
ministre
est-ce que c'était une décision
difficile à monter très extrêmes
maintien
j'avais rencontré monsieur lévesque pour
lui remettre personnellement ma lettre
de démission et c'était très difficile
pourquoi c'est comme un peu grosse
chicane de famille louise harel qui
demeure député reviendra au conseil des
ministres dans le gouvernement de
jacques parizeau puis de lucien bouchard
à qui elle offre sa démission lors d'un
bras de fer
je ne voulais pas faire 75 millions de
de compression de coupures à l'aide
sociale
il y avait une limite que je voulais pas
franchir je lui dis je peux comprendre
que le gouvernement a peut-être besoin
mais moi je ne le ferai pas ici alors si
tu veux nommer quelqu'un donc je te
laisse donc si vous habitez le ministre
non j'ai pas eu à faire la compression
selon madame harel il faut beaucoup
d'expérience pour maîtriser l'art du
compromis acceptable celui qui ne
violent pas nos convictions
pour les néophytes qui plonge en
politique dans le but de faire avancer
une cause spécifique
le choc de la realpolitik peut faire mal
tout-à-fait désillusionnés parce que je
me disais nous avons trahi une entrée
nos engagements l'avocat qui défend des
accidentés de la route s'était joint aux
libéraux en 2003 parce que jean charest
s'était engagé à réformer l'assurance
automobile
les tribunaux administratifs et à
réduire les délais judiciaires
mais dix mois après l'élection le
premier ministre lui dit que ces
réformes sont reportés à un deuxième
mandat
alors j'ai décidé de démissionner même
quand j'ai quitté mes juges auraient a
dit mais vous savez bellemare n'est pas
assez patient on va les faire les
réformes à ça fait 14 ans qu'on attend
finition encore été faite à la il y
avait vraiment jamais eu l'intention de
livrer marc bellemare admet que les
ministres puissants comme philippe
couillard sous jean charest et gaétan
barrette réussissent mieux que les
ministres aux petits budgets et il est
particulièrement difficile de défendre
l'environnement dans tous les
gouvernements à chaque jour tu dois
gérer par inexpérience parce que j'ai
porté le longtemps je dois gérer le coup
de gueule intérieur doit gérer le trouve
que ça aura pas de bon sens yves
françois blanchet était ministre de
l'environnement sous pauline marois
il a autorisé la cimenterie de
port-daniel un des plus gros émetteurs
de gaz à effet de serre du québec sans
imposer d'audiences publiques
quand et de bain que les au centre d'une
toile de pression qui s'exerce par
plusieurs autres ministères dont tu es
l'empêcheur de tourner en rond
ça se fait au prix de ne pas réussir à
imposer toutes les conditions que
j'aurais voulu imposer pour par daniel
l'ex ministre juge qu'à force de faire
des compromis
les politiciens oublient parfois de
protéger le public contre certains
pesticides par exemple les
néonicotinoïdes c'était de sortir sa de
la circulation qu'on n'a jamais réussi à
faire
après ça les gouvernements vont de
compromis en france creuse jusqu'à ce
qu'on ne fasse pas ce qu'il faut faire
parfois
l'usagé d'insecticides en agriculture et
l les combats du ministre français de
l'environnement nicolas hulot a jugé
qu'il serait désormais plus utile comme
militant que comme politicien sophie
langlois radio canada montréal